we've built a tables in this battleship
arena first one to pop all five balloons
wins let's go
and if you're new the channel remember
to subscribe to help our channel raise
two million okay that's set there what's
your strategy placing developments
trying to not get tensed popped let the
battle starts I'm really nervous
okay first throw I thought get ready for
some explosions oh not for that this is
so scary
[Applause]
I heard that's good okay continue off
come you're on a streak yeah that's so
lucky get ready for the third one I
think it's somewhere there oh no I feel
like what close yes nice shot keep it
coming me I also give you two in a row
just to make it fast
yeah not with that you're not
not even close after I know neither was
that
ah
oh I almost heard the pop that get they
H off the table
nice jackpot it's two tuna I had a
feeling that he'd put it short I go for
another short one
[Applause]
there does that count
well I think it can't see ya three in a
row
they are canta near okay three to meet
Best Leading still two left where might
they be much they be that was my small
one where my toughest one be think it's
short one or maybe it's in the corner I
try to go on the corner once more okay I
think I'll go [ __ ] does this square
[Music]
No
[Applause]
yeah thank you no I was aiming for this
one no it was the one was quite bloated
but like here okay so this was a fun
concept if you like this next time it
will be off - against ml don't forget to
hit subscribe and watch our previous
episodes there until next time